what's going on everybody it's warren
and we just watched the very first
episode of the loki series on disney
plus
i hope everybody enjoyed it as much as i
did the first episode was a great
combination of
setting up what is about to happen while
combining a lot of different aspects to
the story
of loki this new loki that we have who
has found himself taken out of the main
sacred timeline and into the possession
of the tva
where we get a lot of comedy and are
introduced to a lot of different
awesome characters but there are some
key moments in this especially at the
end that you need to know about
to grasp what is actually going on here
so this is going to be my loki
episode 1 ending explained video
combined with a little bit of an
explanation of some other things that
happened
in this episode as well and i'll be
doing a lot of loki videos in the
upcoming weeks when the series is coming
out so don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos so this
won't be my full episode breakdown
that'll come out tomorrow but there are
a few key points that we have to go over
for this indian explain video and the
first one
is loki getting taken into the
possession of the tva
now loki has never heard of the tva
before and as
owen wilson's character mobius m mobius
explains later on
he never knew about them because he
never needed to
now one thing that you need to know
about the tva is it exists
outside of time i'm sure most people got
the gist of this but it's kind of
vaguely alluded to
when loki and mobius are in the elevator
and loki asks mobius how long he's been
there for and mobius says well that
depends
time works differently at the tva so you
have to realize that these people
control time and to control time they
exist
outside of it we were introduced to the
sacred timeline but the tva
is not a part of the sacred timeline
they exist outside
of every timeline there could be and
will be and here's something that you
really need to know because it's really
important for the future of
not only loki but the mcu the first
episode does a great little animated
presentation
of what the tva is and how the sacred
timeline started
notice that they start off by mentioning
the multiverse they said there was a
huge
multiversal war in which there were
countless
unique timelines this is very important
to know and understand because this
could explain a lot
of important future details in the mcu
like
possibly how the mutants could have come
into existence
the mutants might not have been in our
main timeline they could have existed in
a different timeline where things went
very differently however there were the
timekeepers who took
all of the timelines and basically
combined them all into
one sacred timeline which is the main
mcu timeline
thus they could have combined the
mutants into our timeline and now they
all exist together
another very important thing to note
about this story is that it is basically
the secret war storyline
there are two different secret wars
comic book story lines and they are
definitely some of the best story lines
as far as the comic stories go and it
looks like the mcu
starting right here with loki is setting
up the story which is
a bunch of different timelines alternate
realities whatever you want to call them
start to kind of collide into each other
some of the timelines and realities are
getting destroyed and falling apart and
they start to fuse together with other
timelines and other
realities eventually they all kind of
collide into one
and the result is something truly
awesome we get multiple
different versions of characters all
interacting together which is what i
believe
marvel studios is leading to within the
next 10 years or so it's going to be the
next avengers
end game so by that time we'll have the
x-men we'll have the fantastic four and
we can get multiple versions of
wolverine the hulk loki thor iron man
could come back and we could have a
different version of him along with
other different versions as well
black widow could even return nothing is
really off the table and that's
something that is truly exciting about
the future of the mcu so the timekeepers
and the tva control the sacred timeline
and as they explain if anybody steps out
of line and disrupts the timeline it
creates a different branch of time those
are called variants and r loki is a
variant
the main loki was the one that actually
died in avengers infinity war
so r loki the tva has captured and they
put him on trial and they find
him guilty and they were going to reset
him which is just a
kind of nicer term for kill but mobius
owen wilson's character steps in because
he thinks that loki could be useful
now here's where things start to get
really really interesting
loki thinks that the tva is a joke when
in reality they're
kind of the greatest power of the
universe in the grand
universe of which all different
universes exist
in and loki figures this out because
when he tries to escape he stumbles upon
some infinity stones and he finds out
that the tva kind of treats them like
they're nothing they use them for
paperweights he reveals that of course
he tried to use the tesseract plenty of
times
and it didn't work and he says that the
tva is
formidable and this is just one of some
huge
shocks that really make loki start to
question who he
is and what kind of a god he is then of
course
mobius starts to kind of show him his
future and then loki looks onto his
future by himself
he watches his mother die which was his
fault he watches his father die which
was kind of his fault as well
he sobs at both of these then he goes on
to find out that him and his brother
actually do
kind of become brothers and he fights
alongside of thor
and then he watches himself get killed
so this
loki from 2012 the god of mischief
is finding out that he's not as great as
he thinks he is
and this changes him completely he's no
longer running from the tva
and he realizes that he probably can't
go back to his timeline and that
eventually he will probably have to die
but then mobius reveals the reason why
he wants
loki to help him and that is to catch
another version
of himself loki which actually
genuinely shocks loki and part of that
shock is because
loki actually knows that this variant is
stronger than he is
mobius made that very clear he said he
specializes in dangerous
variants are loki said like myself and
owen wilson's character mobius
laughed at him and said no much more
dangerous you're a pussycat compared to
these other variants
and in the final scene we learn just how
dangerous this loki variant
really is throughout the episode we
learned that there was a variant
this dangerous variant that they're
talking about attacking
a tva task force titled the minutemen
this
variant of loki has attacked multiple
different squadrons of minutemen
and this variant has been collecting
timeline reset
charges which is obviously very
dangerous for the tva because these
charges reset
timelines in the final scene we see the
variant do one
last attack before the episode ends on
the tva when the tva first get there
they realize that oil is on the ground
but they think it's just somebody who
randomly discovered a time machine
came back in time to get a lot of oil so
that they could be rich in the future
but then of course they see the hooded
variant approach the hooded variant and
then this loki immediately drops a
lantern on the floor
igniting the oil and the minutemen into
flames
killing them all then after the loki
variant successfully claims
another reset charge so it seems to be
very clear that this loki variant is
setting up a big
attack and it's most likely going to be
towards the tva
because remember even though it's a
variant of loki
it's still loki and as we saw in this
first episode loki really struggled with
the idea of
fate and destiny he basically learned
that the tva kind of sets everybody's
fate and he definitely expressed his
problems with that
saying that if he does something it's
because he did it and he chose to do it
not because the tva deemed it so so we
can assume that this other loki
is like him and doesn't like the idea of
somebody controlling his fate
so what is this loki planning on doing
well it could be planning to
unleash these charges that reset
timelines inside of the tva
it's very clear that a big attack is
coming because this loki variant
is collecting charges and the tva must
realize
this because they know that they need
this loki's help in order to stop the
other one from affecting
other timelines and attacking the tva so
it looks like a
big battle is on its way and that means
pretty soon we're going to have a
loki versus loki and possibly loki vs
loki vs loki vs loki
depending on how many variants show up
pretty soon so be sure to let me know
what you thought of the very first
episode of
the loki series and don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest
loki videos let me know what you rate
loki episode 1
in the comments down below 1 through 10
10 being the highest tomorrow i will
have my full and complete episode
breakdown out so look out for that don't
forget to like
this video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof